.
>>> LEGO BACK INT IN VIDTHE AT
AS C SL THOSE PEVOPS
ARE WAIN INIRBUT CNTE TESTER WA
THLETH
WE'LL CONTINUE T
SOLDIERS. ASE  T SAYINWAS,RAS TT
COMMANDIEN FORLIEUTENANT GENERAR
GOO  ON.
E HEMAPS THAT WE LK ATSHERE RUAA
MCAUSE THEY'TL ALL  OMANY OF T
AND I WOERLOOK AT THAT
VIDEO THERE, DOES THAT GIVE YO
THAT SE PEOPAGE, FRALY STAND
HETHSOTHHAT'S WHAT I'VBEEN SAYSY
E GOGHCAUS ANY
NOW,E OPPOSITE O
ALOF THAT.
LEADER. A COT
IT'S OBVIO
SUPPORTG  BASED ONHE AMO WE'N V
AND WHAT I WOULD AO AT,
THE N WNBE
WH W THE LAST LOUS MY EW
FE, YOU SA
THF TH OF THATRA
STUDIED THIS WAR
ENNG AT TH
DDAVPELYWERE TO  TTHTHAT'S PY I.
THEY HAVE PUSHED --  SILY ANDT W
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
>>INUE TO KILL CITIZENS
ANAR
TE NGIGHT, MORE AND MOR
TARGETING OF CIVILIAN
CIVILIANS, WE HAVE
T LEAST THE DEPUTY  THE TOWN TO
APARIA
TARGET-- THAT IS PUTIN'S .
THORAYHEA
>>ND, JIM.E. HKN--N A IRE ULBURE
BUT WHATE AMPLES THAT HAVE
THEY DID THEG UNDER A
GOT THEYTROLLED
INA ANTH
FIGHTI B LOCAL E
HAT IS A--ADY ISPARTLY GA
MADE THRGHTRE TO DESTROYS SSVAN
SIZE O
HANDLE IT.E TAKE TOO MUCH Y'RE T
TH ABL SRTTHEIR  IN  IE HE.
NG TO BEE
GOING TOE H PHRASE I USED TEN
DAYS AGO.,
NATO, THKE
NE
PRESIDEN, SAIDAT HE WOULD TREAR
ASART OFN ARMED NFED TO  WAR ON
WHAT, IS STESHORT OF
THAT THAD HE UKRANAL AIRD TANK
ANTITANK WNS, SUPP
BYRMS OF SMALL ARMS FOR THE WI
IPNSOFHAVE ALREADY BEE CSH BODY
K TH
PART THAT WE'T TAL IS TARGETIN
NOW,T D SAY IS
TO HIT.T WE -E EDS AND  ARE GIVL
RUSSIAN FORCESRE BE HEADING, ER.
>> YEAH, AND OTHOTT, BY U.S. AN.
GENERAL, THANKS SO MUCH AS
ALWA.
>> YOU GOT.
VLADIMIR PUTIN, AS WE WERE JUSSR
NO-F ZE HEREEARING
BETWEEN NACES AN
ANTONY INN N MEETINO
REGION AND PLEDGING FINAIAASST E
BRUSSELS.UAR
Y SHG OU MIGY,COTRACING.G TO CO
ALSO TRAVELING TO POLANDNDA NEXO
EVERYONE OTHTHE CRISIS IUKRAINEE
TSO SHOW
R HOPO  I00ES FLEEN  THEM G AN
LYERICAN SOLDIERS THERE.POLAE RO
ELL AS
TRANSITS  EOSE COUNTRIES THATS.
BLINKEN  NOW O
T WHAT THENCHE
UKRAINIANS AOING IS E WORLD.
INSPIRINE WO DOING IS